okay
we are here to do an incremental
language development meeting for
language we are approaching a new
version
so usually that means there's all kinds
of intensity here although this agenda
looks to be
he says um looks to be comparatively
light but we'll see what happens here
okay so this is about finalizing details
about combinator apply
and it actually something we could do
today is to start the rough page of
community reply because that will force
us
to think about details and
yeah so the pro the properties section
above
so yeah let's focus first on
on the first subsection okay
so yeah so
open properties
right so these are the properties that
we will have for
combinator apply and
there are two things we wanted to
discuss with you are we happy with the
name
so so what this is is this is
a function application
that groups it's like the at sign but it
groups the other way
right yes but it's some sort of formal
application it would not
actually do the application
it's it's is that correct roman
it's
ramen
it's ramen here um yes he was here
so can i run this in a 12-2
head branch build the symbol is not
there yet it will be added when we add
these properties that we are finalizing
uh for the moment we always use lefty
as a surrogate okay
um but i'm just trying to understand it
i mean this is going to be represented
by some kind of circle for application
is that correct
yes that's the that's the second part of
the discussion the glyphs we have
ideas below
exactly so the what we are thinking of
is some sort of c
with a dot something that looks it's
like a small
hat something that looks very very
something that looks very close to at
but this is smaller because typically
this is represented with just a space
in a blank so something small would be
nice
roman are you here he's here but
we can't hear you roman
audio problems okay
um okay
again i want to understand so so what we
have right now how does this relate
to um you know at star
so f at star g
applied to x
is is again it doesn't immediately
evaluate
right because f and g don't evaluate but
if on the other hand i
i've replaced f and g um
by lists
the heck is that let's look at the full
form of the
first result
i see so what i needed to do here if i
wanted to get what i wanted there
was do this right
okay so in this case with combinator
apply
so the discussion is is the previous
subsection the wall
the one called presence okay
just before the eclipse
here no further down you see
there exactly
okay but this is i i'm not sure i
understand the very basic thing
um we do need roman here so
um this
represents left
application left associative application
right
yes okay
so normally um
so yeah so the thing is that in in the
first
expression abc we would normally think
of b
applied to c and then a applied to that
thing
but here yeah we see e is applied to b
and then that whole thing is applied to
c
um yes
so with respect to composition i think
what we should do
here is to have um
combinator applied to have a bit less
precedence than
than composition did we already agree on
the combination reply name
we discussed a number of other
possibilities but uh
this seemed so
in the history of mathematical logic
okay
and we may need to get a different
person here
let's see if we can get um matthew
sudzik to join us for a minute
here um
the what was this called i mean this is
the kind of application that is normally
done in mathematical logic
and what do they call it
i mean function application i mean
because for them it's the only thing
that there is there so
but to what extent do they
think of it as applying a combinator
i mean okay we need to look at the full
spectrum of names here
so this is um
between composition and at sign okay so
what what is it that you want to be able
to do
so yeah that's i think seat is fine or
unless we call it left
you know left function i mean with
composition
we've also got um
f slash star g
right and that is called right
composition
what is the difference i'm so confused
here what's the difference between
this
okay
okay so that applied to x
is that whereas what we want
in right composition let's see i see
yes so right composition is about
whether it goes as first element or
second element
here we still something we still want
something that has the
function on the left the function to be
applied it's just that we want it to be
left associative rather than right
associative
but could we imagine a right combinator
apply does that make sense
um and it does combinator applies at
only two arguments or does combinator
apply
is it is it just binary function
application or is it
can it have more can it be there hogs
no i don't think so i think it's it's
just binary because all these things are
always
unary functions
uh do you mind if i interject something
so um in this in the standard kind of
equational way of setting up combinatory
logic
uh yeah the the combinator apply is just
a pure
you know binary operation that satisfies
no additional axioms
right so you don't assume any
associativity or commutativity or
anything
it's just it's a it's a pure formal
binary operation
that's used in the inductive definition
of combinatory terms
so you say you know if x is a variable
then x is a term if x is a constant then
x is a term
and if x and y are both terms then x
compose y is a term
and that's that's the extent of the
definition um
okay okay but were you going to say more
than that were you going to say there
are others some other axiomatic set up
where there's more defined
no i i don't i don't think so i mean
there's there are equational calculator
in equation or calculi but they all
basically just say this is a pure formal
binary operation
there's no additional structure to it
right although we can't have sort of
pure formal right we need we need an
associativity because it has to parse to
something
right right and generally it's still
going to be a two arguments function
right after person okay do we think
hi roman my goodness just about
everything i tried it didn't work and so
finally i had to call in and so
sorry but that was okay very strange
did you hear us or did or did you not
hear us either
i i heard you but for the last minute i
had to disconnect
okay all right so we were talking about
the glyph
that's what i understood
yes okay but okay we were talking about
the name combinator apply
yes what makes it explain why it's the
word has the word combinator in it
well just because it's the main
operation for combinatory logic
okay so so i think matthew just joined
as well is that right
so okay
commentary logic has its day in the sun
but is this
is this operator is that is it
appropriate to call this left
left function application operator
something with combinator in
matthew jonathan roman your comments yes
i mean we
we intend to use it to supply
algorithms and functions that support
combinators right that's that's its
purpose
no i understand that but is it a more
general concept
what would be i mean matthew perhaps
you've been
most involved in mathematical logic
history or something
what would you say about that well i i i
just joined
um so i'm not entirely sure what's going
on but
uh i will say that function application
uh when you write combinators uh when
you write them
let's say when you curry them
it is left associative so so
i know we're trying to introduce a glyph
that represents left associative
function application
correct and we want to know what the
name for that that operation should be
i mean we could call it left function
application
that would be crazy that'd be entirely
appropriate
actually so i think the difference is
between
mathematics and computer science i think
in computer science
function application is often right
associative but in mathematics
it's preferred to be left associative so
there are two different conventions
there
right well we have invisible application
right so uh we could just call it
left application if we wanted to
what is an invisible application is a is
a symbol name right
and sorry is a it's a character it's a
unicode operator
that you know parses as
you know just normal application
you can't have the left one right you
need only the one between the f and the
x
by the way on the subject i hope you
guys like my proposal i should have made
years ago
that we turned this thing into
uh the function symbol
don't you like that proposal
isn't that a lovely idea i haven't
thought it all the way through
um okay i don't i don't think it can
have any
uh different precedence from what the no
operator does
absolutely not right well as far as i
know we just have to check that we got
the precedence right for the unicode
operator
which i think we did but i just think
this is really nice because i really
like using
this but i very rarely do it and if
there was a keyboard way to get it i
think i would do it much more often
um okay so
you know to me left application makes
more sense than combinator apply
well um i think the problem is that add
itself
is also a left application so the left
here is not about
the left as in composition or right
composition it's about associativity
of the parsing yeah okay
well in what sense is it okay what is
the description of that
it isn't described i understand it's not
described but would it be unreasonable
to call it combinator apply would it be
unreasonable to
use the combinator brand matthew to
describe that kind of function
application
what is a combination yeah so so
i i i it's used much more generally
in in mathematics than just combinators
combinators are
sort of a nice little subset where it's
used but it's used much more generally
in in mathematics um you could call it
lambda calculus instead of combinators
and that
that's slightly more general but you
know it's
somewhat even more general than that
if we want to use this as a general
application then
we probably would end up having
meaning attached to it and then that
will preclude it
from being used for combinators
well i know some but okay the question
is if you take one of these things and
you apply it to x what happens
you mean the square bracket application
yes square bracket application what does
it do
well well in combinators the the the
little
your t symbol would be the application
symbol so so you just
t it with x and then that would that
would apply the function to x
i know but what happens in our world if
you take that
t a t thing and you use a square bracket
application to x
what would it do
what should it do
i mean you could argue either way you
could say it should
turn the square bracket application into
a combinator application
or you could go the other way around and
say the presence of the
square bracket x would mean that
everything should
should turn into the normal application
i don't know which is more useful or
whether we should just leave it alone
and not really
deal with that case because it's kind of
a mixture
of two things that don't mix very well
well it's a question is
it's a it will be a sub value
for this nested combinator apply
right yes
well if we decide to do anything with it
it wouldn't be a sub value for
combinator apply
but i'm confused now
so sorry just let me say one thing i
thought the whole point of combinator
apply is that it would not convert into
f of x
it would stay as combinator value of f
comma x
yes that is for sure the question is
if you take combinator apply
of f g of x like that what does it do
maybe nothing i mean the simplest thing
is for it to do nothing
okay so
okay so matthew's point is this is
a way of making a composite function
by which happens to be left associative
as a glyph
but once made what is the difference
between what it makes and a standard
composition
other than that its application doesn't
do anything
well the the a's b's and c's themselves
might actually be
arguments not functions when you're
composing your composing functions
uh but in this case
they might not be functions they might
be arguments
um
oh no i'm even more confused go ahead
yeah right in a sense this is
uh a left associative compose which we
don't have an operator for
but okay so what would happen if we just
made this
be an operator for composition
okay so right now we have that operator
for composition so if we say
fg composition of fg so we do the left
composition here so the fg
composition h what does that look like
what so that is does not have
parentheses
which is exactly what we want for the
combinator case
that that doesn't have parentheses am i
right
now that may have auto evaluated i mean
what's the full form of that
right composition is flat it's a product
oh i see so the difference here is that
this is a composition
that doesn't have auto composition rules
is that right
or so so combinatory application
function application is not taken
to be flat like this is that
is that correct that's correct yes
okay so that's the fundamental
difference here always binary
i i think another difference is that we
distinguish
composition as a product from the actual
from the actual application which we
call construct
then combinator apply is equivalent of
construct
not of composition yes
but so matthew is saying that
combinators okay
what is the definition of a combinator
the most general definition of a
combinator
well as opposed to a lambda for example
well uh a proper combinator is
is just an example of of a lambda term
uh where you know it's just lambda of
some variables with some sort of
argument right
it doesn't have any hanging variables
anywhere right exactly no
no no no uh no free variables the lambda
doesn't contain other lambdas inside of
it you know it's just it's just
one lambda expression what is that
lambda doesn't contain any other lambdas
is that an important requirement i mean
in other words could we have
could our function composition here be
one where
in a sense it has a nested lambda in it
well well
yeah they're they're proper combinators
and there are ones that aren't proper
the proper
combinators are the ones that don't have
the nested lambdas
okay but so i don't care whether it's an
improper combinator so long as it's a
combinator
sometimes it has the tag combinator i'm
good with it but most of the time when
people say combinator they actually mean
proper combinator
okay but what's the more general concept
here
it's it's
ethan on the livestream is saying that
the analog function would be lambda star
what the heck is lambda star
matthew do you know what lambda star is
not off the top of my head
no okay okay so
so say again exactly what this is this
is a composition
this is a combinator compose or
combinator composition is that correct
well as i said before i i think the idea
of
assigning this to combinators is sort of
misleading where
it's it's really just functions it's
it's it's function application
but it's not because it doesn't have the
flatness property
of standard function composition but
this this is the way function
composition
is modeled though in mathematical logic
is what is without
exactly this way so so
this is the way that that it's treated
in mathematical logic what is what is
the this
you uh you're your left t your
your left so binary the point is it's a
binary thing
and is it is it like binary composition
is that the right
you know is that the right term
but no no again composition is a product
of functions
not application application is construct
in in composition all the arguments are
functions
in construct or in combinator apply the
first
function the second is the x to which it
is being applied
not a function it could be a function
too but not necessarily
i see you're saying well i don't
understand why we need to think about
that look the construct case is
you know is that okay where it's at
two different levels the composition
case
is still you know i don't understand why
there's a difference between this
and the combinator case you know in
other words if i say
if you say in the combinators a lefty
b lefty c
you know well you have up on the upper
left corner
up there if you have that um b and c
themselves could be
arguments maybe a is the only function
in b and c are arguments so you've like
curried the arguments it's like a given
two arguments b and c
sure well that's different than function
composition you're not composing
functions
it's it's one function with two
arguments okay what is this operation
what would it be called in a
mathematical logic book what is i
even have a function application i have
a copy
called function application i have
cleanies um
uh actually i have both hilbert for
various reasons i happen to have
right at hand cleaning his introduction
to metal mathematics
what would be what he
he says functions he has a section
called functions hold on a second while
i get his copy my copy also
well i'm not sure if this is the right
place to look but i mean
i'm not sure that all this is the right
place to look it's not obvious it even
has
no i'm not even seeing anything
particularly useful here
um
oh boy this was supposed to be a super
straightforward meeting
okay we're okay any who has an idea here
jonathan do you have any ideas
uh about whether it's combinatory or
more general
about what the heck it should be called
um yeah
i i like the idea of keeping composition
the way it is
as a flat thing and then having
construct
be both kind of left associative and
right associative
that seems like the but when this has
nothing to do with construct because it
doesn't have function arguments like
this
okay right sorry it's a some analog of
construct that is
that is your application right so you
you produce some composition of
functions
and then you know the only question is
are you are you then going to compose
them
in a right associative way or a left
association what about the word
application
well that would be the that would be the
actual combinatory logic term
as far as i know that that is what
that's what this binary operation is
called it's just called application
maybe we should just call it application
nick on our live stream is commenting
this operation in haskell is just a
space
right yeah well we we we used up what
the operator called space a long time
ago
it's called times yeah right the
um i think i'm writing down that's cool
is left associative by default
which is completely crazy let's be clear
i mean just
but just for it's one of those quick
sonic ideas that that
no no no it's following the mathematical
tradition haskell
yes i know but the mathematical
tradition is not useful for
for the way people actually think about
you know functions that do things
it's useful for functions that don't do
things like combinators
okay i am favoring the name application
for this thing okay
wait a minute let hit i attack it please
go ahead that's a very
general name for
you know for a system symbol it is a
very general name
and maybe it's too general but um do we
have a section do we have a thing called
combinators or do we have
do we put in the sound of functional
programming yeah that's where other
things have been
so i i think our big problem here is
that we don't have the symbol of at
and what we are discussing here is the
symbol for the left associative version
of
art and so when anything we create
will be considered to be the symbol of
act
and that's why we have to be careful
yes but i mean the the fact is it could
be the case at some time in the future
that there could be some
you know generalized keyboard way of
getting this if it turns out to be
useful i mean the fact that we've not
found it useful in 30 years
is a sign
look the thing i like about the name
application
i don't think we're going to use it as
another kind of system symbol because i
don't think it's a name that was sort of
a marketing name for programs
that i just don't think we're going to
end up using there
it has a generality to it it is
something that is not
crazy from a mathematical logic point of
view is it is it the correct name for a
mathematical logic point of view
yes so yeah i'm pretty sure again in the
equation constructions of cl that i've
seen
that that binary operation is called
application
then i think that's a good name for it i
mean my my concern is that we might be
tempted to actually
use it and attach meaning to it which
would then preclude it from being used
in a purely symbolic way for doing
for doing combinatory things
but what what meaning will we i think
we're only going to give it a meaning
when we actually have a function
we'll take this we'll have a function
that eats this and does something with
it
can you change the g to an x because
that's what it is
well you might think of it as that i
mean that that x might be a church
numeral it's just made of combinators
x is any argument it might it might be a
function but
uh it i think it makes it clear that we
are not
inventing another form of composition
right it's certainly a very elegant name
i'm not sure it's something we
we want to use here
i mean it could have up values right if
that f is something like
the sine function so we are not talking
about
combinators but if we misuse it for
non-combinatory things
then it could probably evaluate
application identification key what the
heck is that
well it's not even documented
i'd prefer to use this for an operation
in mathematical logic
than an operation than the than the you
know
than that form of application um
ethan is pointing out that you might
actually want to use okay so the
question is
what if you wanted to ma mix
boy this is obscure i mean what if you
want to mix
s's and k's and
woof what the heck is the c there that's
just perverse
but you could do it i mean that's the
question is
is okay let me let me just describe one
other
one other thing okay so i've had a long
quest
for how to make graphical programming
work
right we know that f of g of x can be
represented
as a you know as a graph where we go
you know f to g no x
x to g g to f
right and we can do that as a graph with
vertex labels
actually which should be edge labels i'm
not doing this correctly
okay roughly like that right now
what if we want to do a version of this
in which
we are not in which we have two variable
two argument functions
and we have other more complicated
things going on in which we want to
basically
be be essentially running variables
around this
then one way to do that is with
combinators yes
silence i mean right there's a practical
way to do this
isn't there i mean if i wanted to
represent something where i've
effectively got with
you know u equals you know
something or other u equals f of x
um you know g of u
i don't even know am i talking sense or
am i not talking sense
is is there a way of specifying
essentially the series and parallel
circuit
that i can make for routing information
around using combinators
roman jonathan matthew somebody am i
right
am i completely wrong i mean i i think
so right i mean the the serial
composition is just
combinator composition and then the
parallel composition is just you know
things like as combinations placed side
by side
i think so but then the question is if i
were to write
normally okay so here's the here's the
issue normally
i can do this by having a function with
named variables right
but combinators potentially allow me to
have a function i mean just like
okay reverse supplied is an example of
something where we are using
where we're using something which which
is a you know a variable reduction
measure if you understand what i'm
saying we could do this with variables
or with explicit you know hash signs in
a function
but we're doing it without that and my
question is what's the general way of
doing this
and is there a human understandable way
of doing this with some form of
combinators
combinators were certainly invented for
exactly this kind of
avoiding variables and but i know
but the question is in 100 years have we
managed to find a practical way to do
that
go ahead oh i have a more general
question which is what is the
relationship between
s and as somebody who's barely knows
anything about combinators so
maybe i'm asking a very stupid question
but what is the relationship between
this s and k
and application because my understanding
was that
application was going to be representing
one of these fundamental operations
no s and k are just random combinators
that are where you this application
thing
has s's and k's in it the s's and k's
when they are evaluated do things
to their curried arguments ac
but application is the merely structural
combination of s's and k's
okay okay so the question is the problem
with sk combinators is that nobody
understands them
right and they're not very intuitive and
the question is
is there a more intuitive form of
combinators where we say something like
you know
serial apply parallel apply bad name but
you know
well your reverse supply is just the c
combinator actually
okay what is the generalization of that
idea
of what reverse supplied is doing here
well i mean there are a whole bunch of
famous combinators that do various
things
for example well like like the c
combinator technically the c
combinator it would take three curried
arguments f
x y and it would give you f
y x okay output
okay all right
fine um
okay so what's another example of a
famous combinator that we might be able
to
use as a headdress like this uh
there should be a list on the left
somewhere
notable combinators there well
multiple commenters yeah c
w y and s and k are the ones we should
support and i mean that's another
question do we name them after their
inventor or do we say
combinator b combinator why
i think it's really hard to name i think
nobody knows the inventors of most of
these things i mean like
you should just call them i think
combinator yeah yeah i think so
yeah um because the the letters are
fairly standard so we are not running
into trouble there
right i mean i am i am in the process of
doing
i will know more about moses sean finkel
than
people have known for many years soon um
and i will be able to tell you many
details about how he came to invent
the sk combinators but um we're still
in in the research process there if
anybody knows that well never mind
go ahead i i think i'm right in saying
that the b
combinator should be very closely
related to curry
applied right
i think i'm going in the same direction
matthew's comment was very interesting
because perhaps the
our generalization is just operator
forms
so for example if the c combinator is
reverse applied
what it means is that operator applied
off reverse applied
would be c
operator applied i've always applied
comma three
comma three now write bracket f bracket
x
bracket y
um perhaps two
to change it to two
it has the wrong carrying properties
okay so that's just i don't know what
the
something is wrong with the curry curry
ability here this probably the operator
pride probably needs to be done
in a slightly different way here right
so i i need to think about that but i
think this is the direction
that these combinators in the end become
operators operator forms for us
i think that's right but so that leads
to the question could combinatory parse
of skk
actually be applied to arguments x and y
and do something
i would argue yes i don't see why we
shouldn't give that a sub value
that actually evaluates
well problem big problem here is that
all the interesting terms with s and k
and so have infinite evaluation change
so we have to be i mean we discu
remember in february we discussed this
in great detail going back to
uh evaluation order and evaluation
limits and all the fancy i understand
that i understand so so that
is going to end up being a headdress
okay so look the basic problem is we've
got the notion of a multi-way
combination system is that
is that in the function repository yet
jonathan it is indeed
okay so if i look up resource function
uh multi-way combinator is the name
it's really stupid that you have to
click the button to get to the
documentation
anyway so okay so there's a multi-way
combinator
so do we have us do you have an sk
example here
uh yeah so in scope i have all of the
standard combinators
or at least i say all the standard ones
all the ones that shown fickle mentioned
how far do we have to go to get to scope
you know your notion of basic is very um
generalized okay so there's the ski
combinator
okay so this is looking at
this example here
is combinators applied
okay so this is showing the evaluation
chains this is showing possible
evaluations
and so what we for the sk combinations
so
let's pick an example so so for example
this right here
is something we would like to replace in
in the new world
this thing here will not be function
application
it will be application and this will say
s
application x application y application
z is that correct
yes and that's how we will represent
this combinator term
right and and then that will be applied
to uh you know something which has just
the application operator not uh
function brackets right
yes i mean i think that's the main
reason we want this that we
can right and so what you're now saying
is
with combinators the combinator apply
which might be a real thing would be a
combinator apply
that describes which branch in the
multi-way system we want to actually go
down
right which evaluation chain we want to
follow it might have some way of
parameterizing evaluation chains
as yet unknown right that is our
reference frames for parallel
programming and so on
that defines which evaluation chain we
want to follow
but so so the idea would be so the only
question is
is it meaningful enough and roman is
arguing no
that we want to take sub values to
represent
a fixed point you know a particular
you know if we if we sub value the thing
then it's got to decide which of these
evaluation chains it's going to follow
and our standard evaluation order
represents one of those evaluation
chains potentially a quite random one
making sense
yes i mean the problem is without
control of the evaluation order
let's hope i mean it yes i mean it's
are trivial i mean you you have you have
all the examples in your book right
about
all these exploding chains and
everything
right so right so so i mean okay so what
that's telling us is we shouldn't at
least initially
make the sub value do anything
right yes i mean that's that's right we
should provide
the formalism we should provide those
functions that make it easy to
get into combinators and out of
combinators
i mean getting out of combinators would
be just a way of replacing
the application symbol with the
construct symbol
right so that would be a very easy
way back is that right is that
all you need to do yeah i think it is
yes application turns into construct
yep that sounds right okay so then
i mean hopefully we are going to get
we're not going to get it unfortunately
for 12
2 multi-way system as a system symbol
we still need to do more design on that
and that would then allow us to do
okay and then you know for the future is
evaluation control
all right okay so first decision here is
we're calling this application
now let's discuss what its glyph is
okay um
what would what would it be in
mathematical logic if somebody put that
i understand that most of
it's not i remember in february you
actually discovered that
i don't know whether it was
schweinsteiger somebody else who
actually used the ad sign for exactly
this purpose
and later on later on
uh in because it's the only applica the
only operator symbol in this theory
the people just didn't put anything
right just like multiplication in
in calculus just an empty an empty space
so the standard the standard way of
representing
it is an empty space which of course is
not possible for us
in standard form it could be in
it's not going to traditional form but
and then we thought about something
related to the add symbol but the add
symbol already has a circle around it so
we cannot probably not use an ad symbol
inside a circle
and so and it's also because it's
it's not commutative maybe instead of a
circle we wanted something
a little bit different so we actually
found
devin found that one of the standard
ancient greek characters if you undo the
first one if you look at the
that c shape
that's actually a named character in in
well actually it doesn't it's a it's a
sigma variant
really we absolutely should not use a
named character i mean
an existing unicode character i think
um
i've never seen that sigma variant but
greek
small dotted lunate sigma symbol
i don't think anybody i don't know i
don't know where that comes from
but and so we looked at
things that look similar and something
like pacman symbol
or pac-man symbol
well it looks almost like right i mean
it's well free
but the lines will need to come together
for it to be more pac-man like
so should it be like this or should it
be a three-quarter
circle with a dot which way around the
that you've got both ways round is very
suspicious to me
which way round should it be so remember
it's going to be mixed with parentheses
right so we're going to have things
which say parenthesis
k you know our thing
dot i'm just writing a dot but what will
it look like it'll be things like this
s dot k dot k
you know close paren yes i mean
i mean just like yes okay so it's going
to live with parentheses
okay so given that which way round would
you like that weird symbol to be
pac-man should eat arguments on the
right right
well you mean it should be it should
have its mouth open to the right
i think so yeah i prefer that too
as opposed to right see i i
i mean i'm not the expert here obviously
but
my initial inclination was the other way
around it should be sort of pointing in
the direction
things are moving so i see right moves
that way
okay let's see um push on our live
stream is saying the op
a different operator from multi-way
operator curly cure what is a curly cure
what is a curly cure
um
oh a color q
wait a minute what are we saying a color
cure or color q
um
color q i understand what that is i
don't know what that's explicitly going
to be here
um i mean i color q is a more generic
term for just a
a um let's find out what it is here
oh my just imagine one of those things
i feel like i'm i'm reading spivak with
his hand-drawn
you know greek uh i mean gothic or
uh you know uh yes right
calligraphic operators but that seems to
be a common one
that's definitely a weird operator for
us to use if we say
you know f this thing
that's that's definitely a weirdo um
okay uh
there's one obscure logic book that uses
a vertical bar
that's a bad idea i hate the look of
that i mean that's what people use for
shuffle stroke for nand i hate it
i mean i like a dot okay this is sander
on our live stream just
offers this which looks awfully like a
copyright symbol
but i mean we could certainly make that
thinner in the um
um uh let's see if we went
down here to thickness you know 0.05
here
that looks even more like a copyright
symbol
no i mean i would prefer this to the to
the c
to the subset variant on the left
now the question is is it completely
unthinkable to use some kind of
center circle of some size
you mean just a pure circle like a small
circle
yes which is commonly used for function
composition so we have to be careful
here because it's not exactly function
composition
but how many of these why isn't it
explain what i mean it's a small circle
i don't even know what that positive
that pauses to something
i think okay which is flat
right bizarrely which we do not want
application to be
right well if you think of it as
representing an arbitrary mathematical
composition then it's correct
that it's flat it's not composition it's
application
right but i'm saying yes but the point
is that small circle is used to
typically represent composition
and therefore it is correct that small
circle is flat
yes and small circle probably
therefore cannot be used for application
independent of the size of the small
circle well there are ways we could do
it i mean we could have a small circle
with a little bit of
look for example one thing we could do
is have a small circle with some
blackness on one side of it
but i don't even know which side i don't
know which side which side should be
i think it should be left a half moon
right
yes a half moon that's why we're getting
lunate here
let's see a dotted lunate sigma okay was
used by aristarchus of samothrace says
rickness as an editorial sign indicating
that the line marked as such is at an
incorrect position
it's ancient michael great
ancient editing marks
right so it should always be red right
yeah right they probably didn't have no
they had they had
cochineal die right they had some
crushed beetles or something
so they will have had red red ink
maybe um no but the half moon
with the black on the left black on the
left
okay well let's let's draw that circle
and uh half
disk inside right so you're saying
graphics of circle
and then disk who knows the syntax for
this
zero zero one and then who knows that
syntax
pi uh
you'd want a list uh like pi over two to
or you know minus pi over two or maybe
the other way around
okay let's do it so it wants to be pi to
minus pi over two
oops no pi zero to pi
am i wrong no i'm confused how do i do
this
help i think i have to three by half
okay okay
here we are
that's not absolutely terrible i mean if
that was in
let's let's draw that for a second so
then that's
f that's g
i mean when that's nice and small
could be a lot worse that's not that bad
it's it suggests something
even smaller but yeah oh it can be
smaller yeah like
okay not not that small but somewhere in
between yes
no that i like that i think it's good
i think it suggests i mean
it suggests it's an application but it
suggests it's a bit exotic
okay somebody is suggesting a unicode
character
um how do i do that like this oh
five eight d is that right did that how
i do it
it's very amusing it's not crazy
no it's not
that's very amusing actually what the
heck is it well does that have a
format to sell does it have a long name
right facing armenian eternity sign
okay right but do we have a
long name for it oh yeah i don't i don't
know
but if you just inform unformat the cell
we'll see what it
uh or i guess you could give it the full
form
no we don't have a long name for it
bob is suggesting a diamond shape sort
of interesting
and
i was thinking maybe small circle with
an overlaid arrow
right so it's sort of like between
composition
and function application there's the
character code
um bob put that on a live stream for
this thing
so we could actually use that
there's the yin yang symbol yes um
oh is it well then no it's not the in
the end symbol this isn't the indian
symbol
but i mean we could we could make a um
no that would be silly okay so that the
choices are
the heck is this
what the heck is that
that's just weird but okay so look
the choices are something which has that
sense of direction
right we could imagine
um a sense of direction like this
we could imagine a circular design of
this type like
like the sawmill design
i mean i think this is an interesting
direction maybe not that actual glyph
okay so what we've got on the table is
this kind of glyph or this kind of glyph
probably it cannot be too complicated
because it would be
very small oh dear
well okay so there's an issue with this
one i mean this has this particular one
has a has a whole cultural baggage
associated with it
but it doesn't really matter i mean we
can simplify it
um and apparently it's claimed who knows
but this might be a wikipedia level
claim
that it has some uh
it's the analog of a star of david for
armenia
but also a prehistoric version of a
swastika
so um uh
ethan citizen's lambda it's not
appropriate for bit to be a lambda this
is the infix
form so it's not it's definitely not a
lambda
um okay so anyway look so it's some
uh uh pushes suggesting
make a poll and get mathematicians to
vote on it i i think that is one of
those
that's one of those interesting but
potentially exceptionally doomed
ideas um the
oh no no we don't want something with
that level of structure we really want
something that is um
um uh that has i think we want something
that is
reminiscent of a circle okay so that's
sanders suggestion with a with a diamond
i don't know whether a diamond diamond
hexagon yes
it has an explicit image size so yeah
okay
right so this
i mean that's not terrible either
i mean we've clearly we've got a
backslash back at diamond
which i don't know whether it pauses to
anything right now is it an infix
operator
yes does it pause does it is it have a
certain part of the diamond of fg
and probably flat
that's a mistake to have made all these
things flat probably okay it's flat
it doesn't necessarily matter what about
diamond with a
dot in the middle it's possible
okay so diamond with dots okay so look i
think what we've got here is a number of
viable choices i think we've got either
this thing which is a bit exotic
diamond with a dot look a diamond with a
dot is not crazy because it's got the
dot
in there um
yeah bob is saying he likes the the the
half moon with the because he's got
direction but i'm not sure a direction
is desirable
because we're so confused about what the
direction means
the very fact that we've got you know
that we're considering both these
directions
it's a super bad sign um
what does what direction do we want to
indicate
the fact that the function is on the
left and the argument on the right
this thing is exactly like add that's
why the original suggestion was a very
small ad
right well okay in that case i think
this is not crazy
we should see what it looks like in i
mean you know the other possibility is
something
um the uh
that's very weird that lander is deeply
weird
looks like um isn't that the logo for
like
scheme or something um
okay all right so look let's
provisionally think about this one
okay so it's named application it is
this
i'm not totally sold on this it's either
this or a diamond or diamond with a dot
i think um
now sandra is suggesting a square with a
dot let's see what this does looks like
a diamond with the color direction is
also a possibility
yeah diamond is sort of interesting in
who does that really look good
looks like one of those weird warning
signs
looks a little busy to me
it looks some yeah so i mean i think we
could do the diamond
with black and white we could do the
circle with black and white i'm not i'm
not sold on this so i don't think this
looks that good
now the only thing that is interesting
about the dot
concept is one of the things we did want
to bring up
is we've got all these things formal a
and so on
which is our way of
of indicating this is a formal variable
now one of the things that's come up
is the need to have formal operators of
all kinds
and so that raises the possibility of
dotted operators
like let's say you want to have a formal
rule operator
which has the um the syntax of rule but
does not actually evaluate like rule
is it conceivable that we could have
dotted versions of all operators
why does this come up this comes up
because axiomatic theory
needs to have i mean if we pick the
ring axioms there um
okay so here right we've got a bunch of
different operators we need to represent
and we're kind of cheating here by just
using
this operator the plus i mean for rings
is probably reasonable
right but even that tilde zero i don't
know what that means is that is that a
negation operation or something
i don't know what that is the tilde zero
is additive identity
okay it's a zero but it's a formal zero
okay so so that's a case where if we
would have a dotted zero
that would be a good formal zero in
other words this is
basically the formal family is
it's supposed to remind you of such and
such a thing but it isn't that thing
it is merely standing for that thing so
it is more formal than a variable a
variable x
stands for a value an x dot
is serving as a you know it is the thing
that sean finkel tried to
eschew with combinators it is a thing
that
stands there you know holding a place
for something well i guess that's what
the
x dot would be but then the operators of
which sean fingers combinators are in a
sense an example
okay you know one of the design bugs
with combinators was nobody knows what
they mean
right that's the reason why an sk nest
is sort of useless to us whereas
something that has
things called plus and times and so on
is useful because there's naming there
and so the question is in formal axiom
systems can we get
can we have our cake and eat it too can
we get an indication of naming
without the operators actually meaning
anything
jose attai et cetera do you understand
that you understand the point
i think i understand the proposal and we
have a dedicated meeting for this next
week
i mean okay all right fine fine but i'm
just saying that might inform
our dottedness for this operator but
okay look we're going to have a
okay let's let's say it's either the
half moon character or it's something
related that
the curlicue didn't make it um the
um
bob is suggesting
a solid circle operator look i i i think
it's going to be something in the circle
family
it's probably going to be an existing
unicode character i guess i'm
i'm sort of okay with what are people i
think it's okay to do that i think it's
better to do that
so that it will render in other
applications and so on so that
application will render in other
applications not
not to make a pun of it um but it's to
have an ordinary unicode character
do you agree guys um
well i mean that potentially has
issues if anybody has you know
has existing code that uses that
character and that's a letter like form
so in other words
a character that used to be letter like
now becomes an operator
right okay
i suspect in an existing notebook we
could detect that
because that's the only case okay the
case that will be bad
if somebody has a pure text file that
contains this thing used as a letter
like form
and now it becomes an operator or they
just copy and paste it in
in the future uh sure
that seems exotic that that one i think
can be i mean the issue is
they had that you know somebody had one
of these
uh you know half moon things in an ex i
mean if it's in a text cell who cares
the issue is they used it in a symbol
name
i frankly think it's deeply exotic
you know somebody used this as a symbol
name
in i mean the number of people who use
things i don't think most people know
that you can use
arbitrary unicode characters and you
know
what we have done so so listen the in
unicode
we are basically taking the unicode
space and deciding
certain unicode characters are operators
and other ones i mean this is a decision
we made
before the unicode standard even existed
right when we were involved in helping
to define how that would work
um the uh you know back in the early 90s
we made these decisions about
we're going to slice up the space of
glyphs and some of them will be paused
as operators
and some of we paused as letter like
what we're now saying is maybe we want
to move that boundary
of what counts as operators right but
but
man right well yeah i mean i think we
should probably involve john in this
discussion but my my right
when we have used existing code points
as operators
like square root and cube root then
the operator meaning lined up with
the normal meaning of the unicode
character as a character
yes well here you're taking something
that means one thing and using it for
something
as an operator completely unrelated
let's just
check that there isn't a unicode
character for function application
can we check that
we can try
u206 what the heck is this
u206 2061
claims to be a unicode character oh
great
okay okay so that is an invisible apply
unicode 2061 is is an invisible apply
i wonder whether we treat it as that
great no
but but there is a um uh
okay i wonder what code block let's say
unicode
2061
right so we could we could
what the heck are we talking about here
oh i see that's
2 6 1 decimal which is
um so 206 1 so let's see what do i want
to do i want to say
16 wedge wedge 206 1
8289
look at that what do you know
i wonder if it's something that post
dated
version two of the unicode standard
which
was came f out just after version
three of mathematica and therefore
we already had something in the private
unicode area
um before you know before it became part
of the
uh unicode standard
i mean we could support it on input
right yeah we absolutely could support
this on input
and i know i think we need to go and
spelunk a little bit more in the unicode
stand and find out what else is there
but this is this is invisible function
application is not going to do us any
good
um
yeah okay okay so okay let's go back
i know we're over time but i do want to
we we do need to cover this so
so we've now got okay application is the
name
and the character is as yet undetermined
i personally favor using a character in
non-private unicode space
um preferably something which is
plausibly an operator already
uh preferably not something phase of the
moon or something like that
um what about uh to
try uh backslash call in 2050.
okay hold on what what is the character
name for this guy
circle with left half black that's not
terrible i mean that's
at least that's not some kind of you
know
uh you know armenian character or
something right
that's that is a structural object which
i think could plausibly be an operator
which which one would you like me to try
um
2050 decimal law
like that
so it's sort of like a half circle
i don't graphically like it very much um
here let me put something in the url and
[ __ ] close up
i mean i would expect that to be a
letter like form
okay that close-up thing i it reminds me
of a space and so on
no i mean the circle is left half black
does not sound like a
letter-like form so right
that could be okay
what are you showing here right i'm just
saying that there are a bunch of
punctuate
right so once you go down a little bit
there are a bunch of
extra punctuations like two dots black
leftwards bullet
so i don't think we should use something
like this because that makes me
um right well something like dotted
cross or four dot mark
uh those look to me sort of in the same
general family
yeah and the quincunx or whatever it is
there
yes
right we don't want a plus-like thing we
would want a time-like thing
but why is it what is a tyronian sign
at what is tyronian is that like
like place in italy or what no
who knows um
oh there there's the uh the dotted times
203b it's called the reference mark i
don't know what that means
two zero three b
right so that's a couple of times
i bet it's terrible we cannot use that
that looks like some kind of it looks
like some
you know flag of uh you know i don't
know
okay the flag of the independence of of
something or other
oh no it looks like a railroad
clustering warning sign or something
i don't know what it looks like though
um all right but anyway so i i think
this
the what's looking best so far is 9680
okay let's assume it is 9680 then
um what we're doing here
is um uh
um right and
actually i mean another possibility is
we could have it on the
indian in the private unicode space
and then on copy out replace it with the
9680 if if that's the glyph we're using
now then we haven't solved anything
because if the thing comes from text
it's going to be done and copy in as
well
so it doesn't really help
but it doesn't help the compatibility
issue
right but it does it so it solves the
the it displays in other places right
because when you copy it out
sure but i i think we should just use it
in our own i i personally favor using it
we should talk about when we talk about
formal symbols but i i personally favor
just
just saying we're capturing it
that's life that's the advance of of the
world is that we're you know we're we're
using a glyph for an operator
right but we could use the glyph without
using the code point
and it seems not in the spirit of you
okay
let's discuss the code point issues
separately okay
no i'm not certain either way about that
but let's just
let's just talk about what we are
actually providing here so so then
given that glyph whatever the glyph is
9680 whatever it is
right then um
which right now is a letter like form i
assume i mean i assume if i type in
f that g it's just going to
you know it's going to be a syntax error
oh it's going to be letter like
a symbol yeah it's kind of unfortunate
that it's
okay fine okay terrific so
so anyway so then we're talking about
combinator s
okay which would be formatted in
i don't see why we shouldn't format this
in standard form
as a black letter s so i mean
it's such a common usage to do this this
sort of
black and s i think we should do that
even in i mean uh
even in standard form because i think
otherwise otherwise standard form is
hopeless for dominators
you'll never be able to read anything
boldface some kind of boldface thing yes
that's the standard form but that
probably means we have to have a glyph
for these combinators i mean
that would suggest that we actually have
a glyph combinator s
for every letter combinator a through z
right i mean we
could we don't necessarily have to
right like you like how would you do the
input otherwise
they would have an interpretation box
yeah so do something like
uh you know escape reels escape
okay right and and what is that in fact
well it's reals but the underlying
expression is
uh the underlying boxes is just an
interpretation box
around you know a double struck r
so you're saying if i do command shift e
i will just see the
interpretation box okay i guess it's
actually an
a template i implemented this as a
template box so we could
where's the glyph where's where's the
thing
it's in the display function right it's
a template box
so what that inserted is a template box
it has a you know in chord.nb it has a
style
you know a display function which
displays it but if you don't
right if you're one of those weird
people who likes bold r's rather than
double strip bars
then you can customize your style sheet
to change the display
of that wow i had no idea does anybody
know they can do that
i presented on this at the tech
conference
is there a workflow about doing it uh
no might be a good idea now we could
reference it from all those function
pages
okay interesting idea i i had no idea
that was possible
i had never thought about how this
actually worked so i don't care which of
these mechanisms we use
i mean i would argue that it might be
worth having a glyph that represents
this thing but i have no opinion about
this
okay either mechanism is fine and the
mechanism you just described sounds
easier to implement it's probably fine
for right now
the fact that i've never even known how
this worked there's a sign that doesn't
really matter
how it works underneath okay so then we
would support
um a standard set of combinators maybe
maybe six or seven combinators these
ones here
i've i've never heard of the w
combinator what is the w combinator
that's the argument yeah it's rather
curry's original
combinators
what did it stand for in his world
did he i mean s and k are presumably in
german
anybody know what they are
originally uh k sean finkel used c
instead of k and curry changed it to k
because he was using c for something
else
assume it stands for constant exactly
exactly constant yeah which in german
starts with a k
correct yes but why did
why did sean finger start it with a c
and s stands for fusion
what is that word in german
that doesn't sound very s like no
anybody know it in in russian or
ukrainian
that's where sean finger was from maybe
s stood for sean finkel back in the day
uh hang on there's a this page might be
useful
uh it has a bunch of german words which
i was going to try to pronounce and then
thought better of it
oh okay somebody has a um
uh that's cool
um oh come on that's that's a very
unconvincing
really
sounds more like a way of remembering
them right
yes i think so i don't think that's a um
uh that doesn't seem convincing yes
it's those are mnemonics and very
obscure mnemonics if i might say so
um it's like a typical menu
uh active yeah yeah right right right in
on windows
right the first one that is not already
taken right
right um
okay so
all right so that fine so we're going to
implement those combinators
um
oh okay so the person who put up these
combinator names seems to have a
uh interesting mathematical life cool
the um
the uh um
nick is saying s might stand for
substitution i i suspect no such luck it
would be a
okay let's just look at this thing
combinatory parse
no sean figo called it the fusion
function in his original paper
but he called it s yes but but he he
explicitly called it fuji he said s is
the fusion function
you know sean finkel's paper really was
ahead of its time and the fact that it's
hard to understand 100 years later just
makes it all the more remarkable
anyway we're about to get the whole
story of sean finkel hopefully
interesting character unfortunately
probably tragic story but we'll find
that out
okay church numerals
okay so combinator parse i think is
probably the right name
or is the word parse we haven't really
used parse so
what you know this is like when we say
regular expression
of you know
a b star or something right
that's the same the idea is that it
would actually
just be easier to type skk rather than
s half moon half circle
yes and
with parentheses you'd put parens in
here yeah but where necessary yes
yes of course would we support square
brackets and the
the notation that turing for example
used
i don't think we need anything else i
mean we just need a way to
copy and paste combinator expressions
into our language
fine how would we get that combination
string out go ahead
it would be really nice if we had a
password generator right so we could
actually do that
easily right there are going to be
several possibilities we could have a
combinator convert
and name the possibilities
or combinator string wouldn't that just
be a traditional form
where which would leave out the
the half moon no but we need a
programmatic way to do that we need
combinator string
that actually turns it into i mean which
makes me think that that one could be
from combinator string
and then this would say then what you
could do is from combinator string of
this
and then you could start doing
application of from combinator string
blah blah blah
um all right now what about other
okay how would we convert from a lambda
to combinators
i mean that's that that's the t
transformation down there
okay obviously now going into function
repository
type things
right and then the comment combinatory
reduction that's the whole question of
evaluation control i mean we don't want
this right
discussing that right now i think well
so accommodator reduce would be a
function repository function
um yeah actually bob is pointing out
that this
this combinator thing is very similar to
what we do
in i mean this is interesting analogy
um
oh yeah very similar to that which makes
one wonder whether this should just be
called combinator
ssk
and so if you just had a single letter
that would also give you the
basic combinators exactly which might be
a
good way to um
i mean it's interesting that that is not
a totally crazy way to enter that
combinator
and maybe we don't need to have god
knows how many functions
for all these different combinators we
could have the whole smallian
bird forest of combinators then
without being embarrassed about it i
mean
you would still need that special that
template thing with the
bold face s but there would be several
ways of entering it
right but this would be the textual way
of doing it and the alternative would be
maybe well it could be the template
thing we could have a palette for
combinators or we could potentially have
you know combinator a b c d e s et
cetera
yeah i like this idea of combinator of s
and then
and then combinator string how do we
even get that molecule string out of a
molecule i don't even know
how do we get that anybody know how to
get that
is it oh it probably is yes
probably is of that molecule there um
but um what we don't get to do for
combinators
i don't think is is this operation
oops no i didn't mean that i meant this
that would be much more exotic for
combinators
well i mean that would then go in i mean
3-4 would be the
the way to represent them right right
well or actually more to the point
expression graph
which is the modern form of that which
would look very nice for combinators
um
and uh coming together nicely yes
okay so combinator would be the thing
you get there
and it will it will accept things just
like molecule does nice analogy thank
you very much for that
analogy bob um and uh
combinator string then goes the other
way and turns it into a string
and um then we have combinator reduce
for now a function repository function
now i don't know the lambda calculus
version
i mean i could imagine okay
in in a slightly exotic world that
combinator of function
x y oh that's hopeless
it's hopeless what will we do here of x
of y
of x or something yeah that could work
that could work
turns that into well which combinator
it's not a canonical form of combinators
right
well technically just the
the lambda term itself is a combinator
function y x y x that itself is a
combination you don't have to apply
anything to it
but then what will we do with this thing
so that that thing floats around it's
com i mean what would we how would we
format that
i mean that would suggest we need a
combinator convert is there a canonical
conversion of a lambda
two combinators no because you can use
some random smallian
jaybird thingy or something right yeah i
mean the the t
transformation on the left is what we
are looking at right now
and of course you have i mean that's the
minimal one
right there but that's not very
efficient so that's where all these
extra
combinators like bc and w come come into
play to make it more efficient
but sean finkel didn't know about lambda
calculus because lambda calculus was
invented
10 years after sean finkel right
yes so he but but it's generally
believed that
sean finkel intuitively understood this
t
transformation he just didn't write the
algorithm for it
yeah well it makes sense i mean how
could you how could you invent s without
understanding that transformation
exactly exactly
that's why it's believed that that he
intuitively understood it
right um sorry
naive question does the t transformation
always transform into ski
or cause it could transform into
calculate i
i well
you know you can write s and k in terms
of other things i i mean i i i can be
written as s k
k so you can just write in terms of s
and k and no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no sure
no i i realize that s and k are
universal and the other combinatory
systems of the universe i'm asking in
the formal definition of the t transform
t transformation
it's usually not called t traditionally
it i mean
what's it called it's just called the
abstraction algorithm
okay so okay so let me just record that
because this is
so then we would want combinator
abstract
something combinator abstraction of
a function and that would be that would
turn that into a combinator expression
and it could for example have an option
which would
so you could give the set of combinators
that you want to use
sure why not right so that's all seeing
snk
but of course using some of the other
ones leads to much shorter
results
right yeah this is nice and that way i
mean that's a that's a sort of
compilation
destination that's the instruction set
combinator abstraction
you know targets an instruction set
all right and then combinator reduce
you're saying that we cannot support a
combinator reduce right now
at all i mean we could do the from
combinator abstraction to make it into a
lambda
right if we had that which is
straightforward to do that's a pure
symbolic transformation if we had that
then we would have a lambda which does
evaluate
is that the right terminology so
accommodator abstraction
will take a lambda and turn it is that
the right
meaning for the word abstraction you
abstract to a combinator
no it's the other way around
well don't i think you actually might
sit say it one more time
okay so this would combinator
abstraction would go from lander
to combinators yeah yeah and from
combinator abstraction
would go well actually what this would
be
is really combinator function
of this thing right
so there what we would have is a
combinator expression
to pick up a random combinator
expression here
so this would go from the combinator of
combinator function would go from this
to function of i have no idea what
variables we put well we could do hashes
right we could just do hashes here
couldn't we we could always do
well we only need one hash right because
this is curried
am i right am i wrong how many variables
do we need
no you need you need more because i mean
the intermediate forms don't
don't transform right you you need to
always with s
you it only fires when there are three
arguments right
but so you're saying they are current
but uh so so you don't
so you don't need more than dollar one
but you need net you need to nest them
so you cannot use dollar one because
that's always scoped to the innermost
function
so you need to name them
okay so here so wait a minute so so what
you're saying is we need to name these
fox
variables
as so this thing what's that yeah i mean
it's function dollar one comma function
dollar two comma function
or three comma whatever it is right yes
well actually here there's only one left
because
already supplied two functions but what
should be the default
yeah what will be the default okay so
there so combinator function
would take the bound variables
presumably
as would take its its
binding pool so to speak as it's
an as its first argument
right and it would have a default
binding pool
right so this is like a function except
instead of an ordinary function this is
a function whose
inners are specified by a combinator
so you're saying we can't do this with
our hash variables we can't do
there's no way to have a an anonymous
binding pool
here is that right
yeah i mean well i mean first of all the
name doesn't matter but
you cannot use the hash sign but you
could use
make up some some symbol some dollar
[Music]
k dollar one k dollar two i mean you
could could use module variables right
with the same
same stuff sure or you could use formal
variables for this we could use formal
abc
unless that will cause us trouble for
some reason but i mean this binding it's
better to number them yes
is it better to number them well i mean
it's probably easier to read if you
always start with dollar one ten dollar
to a dollar three
okay but but in general there can be a
binding pool here
and that binding pool could be a named
argument so we might say
um
[Music]
we could just say well the binding pool
could just be the alphabet for example
and then that would just use the letters
of the alphabet and if it runs out of
the letters then it'll give an error
does that make sense and then then we
could also have a symbolic name
we could say binding pool is greek
like this and then that binding pool
i've never heard the term binding pool
but i rather like it i rather like that
concept i mean it's kind of ironic that
one of the
main results from lumber calculus is
that the name of the former variable
doesn't matter now we are
spending so much effort allowing us to
specify that well in the theory the name
of the formal variable doesn't matter
you know you have de bruyne numbering
and all these insane
approach i mean look the the the story
of the name of the formal variable
doesn't matter
is a hundred year old story of of horror
because obviously that's why canonical
forms for lambdas are so difficult et
cetera it's a big mess
it is a name that doesn't matter but yet
is all you have
right because the name has to be i mean
like in in
you know look in our theory of physics
all of reality
is escaped you know escaped bound
variables
ironically enough so yes ironically
we're only discussing that
because that's everything the universe
is made of is escaped lambda variables
um i really like this this is this is
really nice in my view this
notion of a combinator function right
because this will allow us
okay so actually this is really cool
look
look look look look look this is really
cool this will mean
okay so let's walk through what this
actually means this means if you say
combinator function
of combinator s k k k
whatever it is right i don't know my
combinators well enough but then
then we give arguments you know abc that
will just evaluate
now it will evaluate using the
evaluation order of our standard
evaluation order for the function
and if that doesn't terminate your toast
why do you need the combinator function
command can't you just say
just combinator be good enough no
because it doesn't evaluate
that's the point i mean commonly right
now we are imagining
that combinator of s of
x does not evaluate but it doesn't
evaluate traditionally in combinators
either
until you give us three a total of three
arguments well no i forget the
okay let's do a k here okay
k doesn't evaluate until you have two
arguments yeah yeah okay okay but you're
being literal here
um
uh let's see
um okay but but
what we're saying by the way a comment
made by bob here is
what we're doing with combinators seems
an awful lot like with what we're doing
with levels and arrays
and tensor transposition
is that true
gosh jose can you see that at all
well it's a bit like trying to hide
indices and convert them into numbers
it's a bit like that what we are doing
here with trying to hide variables and
convert them into
combinators
i see what you're saying so the issue is
when is it a named level
when is it a positional argument oh boy
okay um
and let's see the question somebody was
mentioning 2d combinatory logic i've
never heard of 2d combinatory logic
what is it that sounds interesting
what is the generalization of of
combinatory logic i don't think you can
do that
usually these things that's that's where
we why we've invented this whole hyper
graph scheme for the physics project is
that is the
analog of um um
um
you know that that's the analog of um
i'm not finding a lot on the web for 2d
commentary logic i'd be interested to
know what that is um
symmetric interaction nets i don't know
what that is
um anybody know 2d combinatory logic
oh boy the symmetric interaction
calculus
oh it was a forum discussion about
analyzing computing with combinators
um
it is really i really it's really
striking to me that it's been a hundred
years since combinations are invented
and yet it's so
hard to oh yeah yeah this is a kid from
the summer camp
yes
oh boy he's done lots of stuff
we should make sure we look at his his
wow he's already done all this stuff
cool
so let me ask a practical question is
is apply on its own useful
without all of the
sure yes because we can put the other
things in the function repository for
now
okay because that's the thing we need as
a built-in thing
okay um
and the representation of the
combinators the s and k and stuff like
that
yes that's all we really need and the
combinator of quotes
s doing something right now everything
else principle for now we could put in
the function repository
it looks like we should ask eric paul if
you'd like to write some of these
because it looks like he really had
a lot of cool stuff here including a
change of basis that's nice
um the okay
i need to go and um uh
i shouldn't you know it's doomed when i
say at the beginning of one of these
meetings
gosh we've got a very simple agenda
that's just a completely doomed idea
i really like this combinator function
thing that's really a thing that will
turn these combinators into
right and i think we can cross the
bridge later if we put that in the
function repository for now
um we can cross the bridge later of
whether we want to have combinators by
default have sub values
right that is make that the default
operation that we do
um okay hold on i just want to look at
this
one thing
tacit programming what on earth is this
which functions to identify the
arguments
there's a theoretical interest getting
getting rid of
variable names getting rid of arguments
of argument names of functions
so it's just like combinators yeah
look the question really is again the
the stretch goal here is
can we make a version of com
is there a way if sean finkel called snk
english words would people actually use
them
he actually called them fusion and
constancy actually
okay but but is there an english word
for a combinator-like
thing that would cause people to
actually use it in other words
right now we have you can combine i mean
right now look we have
f of x you know we know what that is
it's function application right
but but the question is when we have
let's say see this is the thing i want
to understand
if we have some kind of data structure
like this okay
see the thing is what when you flow
imagine the data flow
for for computation and there's one data
flow which is apply function f then g
then h
right what is the other kind of flow
for which combinators would be useful
that's my question
oh what kind of program i mean obviously
you can take a lambda
and you can abstract it to something
that just involves combinators my
question is
what forms of abstraction are human
understandable and useful
it depends on how sophisticated the
human is
no but but i'm saying look look series
and parallel circuits
right you have you have you know things
are flowing through
is that the right analogy in other words
data flows through this network of
evaluations
is it like data can flow sequentially
from f to g to h etc
what does it mean what is parallel what
does parallelization
like in a circuit mean for data
does that mean anything or is that the
wrong operation and if so what is the
right
kind of operation to be thinking about
there
i i suspect that what you need and i
suspect the reason that that
sean finkel's stuff was incomprehensible
is he had no data structures
so for him anytime you have to have a
data structure it is stored as a
combinator
right but maybe by just introducing one
idea like the idea of lists
we could have i mean you know maybe
there are operations and maybe we
already have these operations maybe
they're things like reverse
and so on that are the you know in other
words the thing we operate on
is look okay so here's a speculation
okay
that a list is representing parallel
operations and that what we
in fact this may be correct this may be
correct that in a sense map
is like that what we're doing is
you know what i bet this is right i bet
this is right i bet we already have
these operations
i bet there are things like map and
apply right
that is the operation that takes our
list data structure
and puts it together again
okay or the operation of fold f
x y
that's not what we want what do we want
f of x how do we get f
of x of y
well anyway but i mean my point is how
are we taking
the the things that are
you know combinator-like operations
done is this making any sense to anybody
so you need to construct in the first
argument default
i see
yeah right so so perk injury is is
mentioned on a live stream that that um
sort of execution control in functional
programming
yes i agree we can that is the whole
point here
is once we have a way to think about
this
i mean this this is the same thing once
we have it as combinators we will then
have the question of what is the
evaluation order
see what i'm saying without combinators
we think the evaluation order is
self-evident once we have it as some big
combinator thing
the evaluation order becomes critical
and that is the same statement as the
fact that the
you know the reference frame for doing a
apparel computation matters
although combinators happen to be causal
invariant
therefore if the thing terminates it
will always terminate with the same
thing
all right well that was uh okay i think
we've got a really good conclusion here
and it took a long time um
and uh we'll have to table this thing
for um another time
uh about documentation pages although
that seems like a fairly obvious
direction
right we just didn't know how to start
or
i mean we wanted to to get an idea of
what's needed there
we're going to discuss some of this i'm
sorry sorry sorry so i mean
for this it's yeah i mean right you know
there's an obvious thing to do for this
all right
let's wrap it up that was actually very
useful i mean despite the fact that it
took much longer than we expected
um and now i believe we have another
live stream
um about geometry and graphics which
we will be starting in a moment all
right
thanks everybody thanks to folks on live
stream 2